one of the primary elements of America
as a concept and as a Western democracy
with separation of powers and checks and
balances and a Constitution is that we
don't have a king and we don't have
dictators for life but we have
presidents who can serve two terms and
George Washington himself could have
been king of the United States the
military at one point tried to put in a
monarchy with George Washington as king
and he resisted there was another
opportunity for George Washington to
potentially become king of the US and he
resisted and you might remember that
during the presidency of Barack Obama
the most outrageous the most extreme
arguably the most sort of heretical and
I'm using that sort of tongue-in-cheek
conspiracy theory launched against
Barack Obama was that he would either
change the Constitution to allow himself
a third term or even more insidiously
declare martial law to justify the
indefinite suspension of presidential
elections do you remember those
conspiracy theories now anyone with an
ounce of common sense knew it wasn't
gonna happen Obama never mentioned it
Obama never alluded to it and of course
it didn't happen President Obama left
office on the eighth year on the
anniversary of his eight years in office
and turned over power peacefully that
gets us to 2018 and the Donald Trump
presidency Donald Trump is now openly
expressing a desire to become president
for life to become effectively a
dictator and over the weekend as many of
you know I try to stay away from
politics over the weekend sort of
decompress detoxify but over the weekend
I started hearing about these headlines
Trump says he would like the idea maybe
he will try to become president for life
and I said it can't be true its
clickbait it's fake news it's propaganda
but now it's true Donald Trump is just
thrilled with what Chinese President Xi
Jinping has done which we talked about
on the bonus show last week he changed
the law to allow himself to become to
remain president of China and Donald
Trump says that it's great and maybe
we'll give it a shot someday and I wish
it weren't true I truly do because an
incompetent president is
one thing a compromised president is
another thing and a corrupt president is
yet something else but a president who
thinks that it would be great for the
United States of America to become a
dictatorship is something altogether
different and we know all of this
because of a recording there is a
recording behind closed doors that was
obtained by CNN where Donald Trump said
about Geum ping he's now president for
life president for life now he's great
and look he was able to do that I think
it's great maybe we'll have to give that
a shot
someday I had some hope that Republicans
would see the attempts to subjugate
American elections by foreign by by a
foreign power right Russia as an issue
that should be beyond partisanship but
they didn't see it that way they're
mostly defending Trump I have had the
hope for a long time that the issue of
the swamp would sort of cross party
lines and we'd finally see Republicans
and Democrats truly come together and
say no more cronyism and corruption but
despite Donald Trump breaking his
campaign promises about draining the
swamp Republicans have been mostly
silent can Republicans and Democrats
come together and say no any president
who aspires to end the fundamental
nature of what makes the United States
the United States that person simply
cannot be our president can Republicans
and Democrats come together on that
probably not because Republicans will
say that this was just a joke oh of
course I'm sure it was a joke because I
don't think that Donald Trump enjoys
being president so what he wanted to if
for the remainder of his life maybe not
I think the condition where he would is
he doesn't have any repercussions for
what he does because he's president for
life in a way it's sort of like perfect
for the guy who doesn't really like
dealing with the realities of being
president but you're right the the it's
a joke thing is already spreading
through all the subreddits that are the
usual suspects in the right wing
websites but when are we going to take
the authoritarian fascist with
dictatorial pipedream seriously right
and to the right-wingers and ever
but he's saying that it is a joke and
who said when President Obama was
president that he is going to steal a
third term or suspend democracy
altogether
where are you now right because if your
defense now is Trump isn't serious then
how do you justify ever saying Obama was
going to do it when he didn't joke about
it
he didn't allude to it there was no
actual reason to think that he was going
to do that good luck talking to them
about that yeah and even if these are
just words they still matter because
what the president says is important to
the entire country when he says that
they were good people on both sides in
charlottesville or that he would have
rushed the shooter in parkland
yes gonna have Remicade ramifications if
a president says he likes the idea of
president for life that is a red flag as
Pat is pointing out here if it's a joke
that we laugh off then why was anyone
focused on Obama stealing a third term
even though there was no actually no
actual reason to think he would there is
no bigger red flag than the president
openly saying maybe he'll get a shot at
president for life someday and this is
sort of the most it's the most important
political position in the u.s. the
president threatening to abuse power to
make an attempt at appending the most
basic institutions and parameters of
American politics I'm waiting for the
right to say no more I want to be
pleasantly surprised by them I'm not
going to hold my breath for it though